what's the deal with airplane peanuts
known to be the most offensive podcast
on planet Earth the Legion of skanks
have been a staple of the New York
comedy scene from the beginning of this
new age of podcasting but being the pace
car for the rest of the internet in
charge of finding the line between what
jokes are still fair game versus what's
now considered too far can be a
vulnerable position to be in and after
having their fourth YouTube channel with
over 100,000 subscribers deleted last
week we sat down with one of the key
members of the Legion of skanks to find
out more about their ongoing battle with
censorship on this platform Louis J
Gomez thank you so much for coming on
the show today we're talking to you
about a week after the Legion of skanks
YouTube channel was deleted from YouTube
just wondering has YouTube provided any
real official reasoning for the ban yet
no they haven't they took the channel
down without any strikes or Warnings but
after doing a little bit of research you
know this is like our fourth or fifth
YouTube channel we've had over 100,000
subscribers four times and I think at
this point they don't have to warn us
it's like ban evasion I think they
realize who we are they could probably
look at like you know where we're
signing up from and more than likely if
I had a guess we just started another
YouTube channel more than likely this
one will be taken down eventually as
well we're just sort of playing the game
and and you know we want to put the
podcast where people want to find it the
free version of the show where it's
discoverable so obviously YouTube is a
great platform for that but we're also
using X we're using Rumble and really
we're just putting the free version of
the show wherever people can disc cover
it and find it and we're just going to
you know just play our hand which is
that YouTube likely doesn't really want
the Legion of skanks to be on their
platform yeah I guess that's a really
positive outlook on the whole thing did
it take a while to get to that point I
guess it's been deleted four times so
you've been through it before but just
willing to play the game instead of
getting angry about this whole thing
that seems unfair how did you get to
that point H look unfair is the wrong
word right because you know all of these
platforms have rules that you got to
play by so the reality is very often we
were getting banned for saying and doing
the things that you're not supposed to
do on the platform Legion of skanks it's
known as the most offensive podcast on
Earth in order to do the show that we do
we have to take chances and we have to
sort of tow the line right and we have
to very often we go too far but very
often we've left mudity in or things
that that you know you're not supposed
to leave in on YouTube and but just
human error and mistakes that happens
right so unfair is a weird way to put it
I don't really look at it as unfair you
know a show like Legion of skanks it
doesn't exist on a lot of these forms
for a reason and we have to edit it down
it is a very very mild version of the
show compared to what we put out on our
own platform SO gas digital is is mine
and Ralph Sutton's platform it's the
home the Legion of skanks we do a bonus
episode of the show on the platform
every week it's the uncensored version
of the show you get the show the way
it's really supposed to be you know we
obviously want people to subscribe to it
but um we also have advertisers we have
great advertisers they only advertise on
the shows that are going out on YouTube
iTunes Rumble X you know we have to sort
of play the game a specific way the
reason that we have as many fans that we
have is because we do the type of
content that we do but it's also the
reason that we don't have millions of
downloads it's the reasons that you know
we're not available on mainstream
platforms it's the reasons why we don't
have a legion of skanks television show
or any of these other things that people
have always had in development it's just
because it's just not mainstream it's
kind of supposed to be living in the
shadows the ability to play by these
social media rules it's so important to
comedians staying on these platforms
which has turned into a big way that
they sell tickets has it ever been a
tough Toc ision for you guys to decide
between self censorship to stay on the
platforms or just being yourself the
most offensive podcast on earth like you
said or is that just day one you know
your comedy instincts we're not going to
start cutting ourselves off and just
give the people what they want I started
doing this like most comedians because I
didn't want to really have any rules I
didn't want to have a day job I wanted
to wake up and sort of do what I want to
do every day right that that is the My
Philosophy and that's sort of you know
been the philosophy for I know myself
and the Legion of St a lot of the other
gas digital shows you know I we could
have all done things differently and I
could have tried to play and I did I
shouldn't even say that because we you
know we all tried to do mainstream stuff
I did just for laugh new faces and I did
Last Comic Standing and I've done Comedy
Central and I've done all of the the
meetings the development meetings and
all the things that every young comic
dreams of doing and that didn't work
what worked was being me what worked was
creating my own [__] creating my own
platforms creating the type of Comedy
that I love when I started in comedy
this was it most Comics were saying
[__] up [__] when I started right and
it it the the industry kind of shifted
yes would I rather be rich and and have
more mainstream success in that regard
yeah of course it would be uh wonderful
to snap my fingers open my eyes and go
oh my God I'm a mainstream success but
that's just not what I am and that's
really not what Legion of skanks is I
think I said it before you sort of play
the you have to play the hand right
you're dealt a certain hand you have to
play your cards you know being the most
offensive podcast on Earth it comes with
some restrictions but it also has you
know enabled us to grow one of the most
passionate fan bases in the world I mean
these are different than other comedy
fans you've been to skankfest you know
exactly the type of vibe that these
people have these are hardcore hardcore
fans that will take a [__] bullet for
us with that in mind I mean there's
benefits and negatives sort of
everything I think we've done a pretty
good job at navigating this landscape
and playing by the rules on all these
platforms for the most part like you
know we we do we're not trying to be you
know offensive to get us kicked off of
YouTube there's certain words you can't
say on YouTube We ble them out there
certain things you can't show on YouTube
We bleep it out or we edit it out you
know it's just unfortunate that
sometimes you don't know like we
actually don't know what the reason was
that they took the channel down we there
was no nudity in the episode you know my
friend Tim butterly just had his channel
taken down because they were just
talking about a guy with a big dick
right and they they kept on making fun
of this guy's big hog I guess somebody
reported it for you know gratuitous
sexual content so the rules are a little
bit I I don't really know what the rules
are I'm just trying to you know go with
the flow as it comes to me sad news
related to Lou J Gomez and the whole
Legion of gangs Channel deleted from
YouTube today out of nowhere I don't
know if you've heard about this yet but
their whole channel was removed earlier
today there's been some backlash from
the fans wondering what's going on
YouTube censorship have you heard about
this yet and what are people in that
Circle saying you know I just launched
my brand new show Tim butterly show on
YouTube and they uh gave me a warning
and took it down because we were talking
about a guy with a giant hog so it's
like they don't want you to say anything
these days dude like yeah they're trying
to censor me I just want talk about this
dude's enormous unit and it's like they
they took us down and but there's like I
don't know it's it's very funny to watch
these guys squirm and try to like find
new ways to put their content up but
like I just went up against it and I was
like on I was on the I was on uh live
chat with Google support like I have a
family to support you please you have to
restore my views you have to pull my
video back up I'm trying to get
sponsorship they're like this guy's
talking about giant Hogs and that's the
pro the problem is that louw won't kneel
down to them you just have to beg at the
altar of Google and they'll [__] let
you back on but I think you know it
could be people reporting stuff it could
be once you're sort of on their radar
and you've sort of been um you know
earmarked as like problematic or I I
don't like using the term Shadow band
that's like a really like I don't know
it sounds kind of cheesy so that we're
Shadow ban we say the words you're not
supposed to say on these platforms right
we we we we make fun of you know you
know just all all the things that on
like that's not the message of YouTube
it's not the message of the tech
industry so they're not really trying to
push that to the Forefront and we know
that I'm not I I I definitely don't
complain about it being unfair you know
it would be nice if they would put
Legion of skanks in front of like-minded
podcasts they don't do that though and
and that's just that and we have to work
a little bit harder in order to have
people discover our [__] but the reality
is they discover it in a very organic
way if you are a fan of legion of skanks
it's because a friend of yours it's like
old school it's like Gorilla Marketing a
friend said hey you got to check this
podcast out because none of these
platforms are pushing us in front of
other podcast
yeah that makes sense I guess it's not
unfair cuz you know the rules like
you're saying but it seems unfair still
to me because I know that there's so
many people that want this content and
don't and don't care I don't know it's
just like it's not offensive to some
people to some people it's just jokes
and then it's just frustrating I guess
that the people in charge don't
understand that but there's so many
comedians that have issues with YouTube
from Tim Dylan to theovon so many people
have had these runin but no one actually
ever leaves there's already a new Legion
of gangs Channel like you said there's
probably going to be another one after
this one day what is wrong with Rumble
and why can no one figure out how to be
the first big Rumble comedy podcast you
know we're we're talking to rumble right
now and we're supposed to have a meeting
with them to discuss doing some
exclusive stuff um I'm open to this idea
you know YouTube is the second largest
uh search engine on the planet behind
Google and it is where people are going
to you know look at their content then
Tik Tok is is huge as well but if you
want a long form podcast longer videos I
mean YouTube is where it's at that's
just that you want to be where people
are and you want to that's how people
are going to discover you that's why you
know once Rumble figures out a way where
it has as many users it's simple it's
dollars and cents like everyone this is
a business for everyone everyone it's s
like a cash grab for comedians right
people sometimes say that they're like
oh it's a cash grab they're just trying
to make money we all spent a decade
making nothing literally nothing we've
in we invested a decade minimum every
comic that you that you've heard of
every comic you've talked about on this
uh in this interview every comic that is
on your channel that is regularly
featured they spent at minimum 10 years
making nothing and putting Blind Faith
into the fact that one day they can
maybe make a little bit of cash off
their dick jokes yeah I I I I just feel
like it's a business and we have to
treat it as such for a while in the
beginning it was just very sexy to be
like dude we're just being funny to be
funny obviously we want to be funny to
be funny uh I I don't do anything that I
don't believe in I'm lucky enough to be
in a position where I don't really even
get involved with projects that don't
have a creative or financial upside
right so it has to sort of be both and
YouTube the reality is if you're looking
to have people in eyes on on your shows
YouTube just has a larger user base and
the second Rumble has a larger user base
everyone will jump ship to rumble
because it's dollars and cents in this
business in podcasting and in standup
you eat what you kill so maybe Rumble
has to figure out a way that they can um
you know change their algorithm where
they're making podcasters and comedy
podcasters more discoverable because if
Rumble came to me right now and said hey
you know what we're going to put Legion
of skanks as a suggestion for every
comedy podcast for every like minded
podcast or every type of content that
could be related to it we're going to
make sure that you guys are being
discovered and you're being put in front
of them so you have an opportunity uh
for people to become fans of your
content I would jump over to rumble in a
heartbeat because in my opinion I I
think that we do some of the funniest
content in the world you know Legion
skanks is still in my opinion the
funniest podcast on the planet so all we
need is the opportunity for people to
see it two or three shows they're going
to fall in love they're like holy [__]
these guys are doing stuff that nobody
else is doing so I think we're on our
way I think rumble's definitely without
a doubt on its way X without a doubt is
is getting there you know Tucker Carlson
just started doing his show on X massive
massive show I think the the interface
isn't as um easy to use a as YouTube
just for watching videos and watching
videos on your TV but once they figure
out all of those little things and
they're less clunky yeah these are going
to be major competitors to YouTube and
the writings on the wall especially with
this new election cycle coming up it's
going to get nasty it's going to get
really ugly we watched it happen last
time um during uh the last election
cycle once people feel like they're at
War they start going after everything
and they they put a label on everything
that's why people will call Legion of
skanks and gas digital rightwing which
is crazy like you're talking about the
least politically minded people in the
world Dave Dave Smith is in politics but
I mean me and big J are morons I hav
voted since the year 2000 I could give a
[__] less about politics I'm just trying
to say funny [__] so you know I I do
think that two three years from now
you're going to see a lot more
podcasters and comedians on platforms
like X and Rumble specifically because
YouTube is um just really making it
difficult to navigate that landscape
well Louis thank you so much for your
time today uh I really appreciate
talking with you hearing more about this
whole situation is there anything else
that the legionis gangs fans should know
that are listening to this anything
about the future of the show or just any
closing statements in general that you
have go subscribe to the new YouTube
channel subscribe on Rumble check us out
on X Legion of skanks uh it's Legion
podcast is the new YouTube channel but
if you really want to support the show
if you love the show and you end up
really liking you want to see the
uncensored ad free version we have over
800 episodes that are not available
anywhere else so our entire library is
on gas digital as exclusive content plus
an extra bonus episode that we do every
week you know there there's a lot of
great member benefits and there's
another 16 shows on the network as well
so there's a ton of content that's all
ad free all uncensored it's not
political it's just funny and that's at
gasd digital.com that's the platform
awesome definitely go check that out
thank you again LS for your time go
check out the new channel and uh
skankfest coming up soon I heard that
yeah J by the way you know you know I
got you some free tickets joke world
you're the [__] man I appreciate your
coverage honestly I I love the channel I
love what you do you do it in a great
way you're you know it's obvious that
you're very passionate about what you do
so I'll always support your stuff and
plug your stuff as well well thank you
that means so much to me thank you for
saying that very kind words LC J Gomez
ladies and gentlemen thanks again even
though it seems like there's more comics
than ever who have very large channels
of their own YouTube as a whole is a
massive platform that has bigger fish to
fry than just comedy podcasting with
over 3 million new videos being uploaded
every single day the rules around
acceptable content on YouTube caters a
lot more towards the hundreds of
millions of users that are on this
platform looking for cooking videos or
children's content so it does make sense
to have some safeguards in place but
there still could be new systems built
that allow grown adults to choose what
they want to watch without permanently
deleting channels that contain years of
history and comments that can't be
replicated even if those videos are
re-uploaded on a new channel different
rules for different channels would be an
easy fix that appeals to both sides but
until there is a legitimate competitor
to YouTube there's really no way for
comedians to gain any leverage which is
something we'll talk about more at the
end of this video guest spots from last
week The Joe Rogan Experience had on
Bobby Lee and the sober October crew
Bobby Lee was also on bertcast two bears
one cave was Burt and Tom Tom and Bert
kill Tony released their New Year's Eve
Arena shows this week Brad Williams was
on we might be drunk Brad was also on
being Ian with Jordan Dusty slay was are
you garbage YH spoke with Jesse Lee
Peterson Rick lman was on tiger belly
Chris Stephano was a guest on Whiskey
ginger as well as bad friends Jan 6 was
a hell of a holiday this year because it
was my holiday of course storming the
capital but then also it's Porter it's
little Christmas I know you said that
it's so wild that's the Puerto Rican
little Christmas so I had a big big day
with that was my big day of the year
little Christmas little Christmas
na what do you do on little Christmas
three kings Three Kings Fest and then
you know Puerto Rico so we just kind of
I give my family gifts wrapped up in
aluminum
foil and they abuse that foil to clean
with it like I'm going to go [__] and
then I said come on this is where we're
going to take our lunch
with best day of the year this best
weekend with Theo Von talked with a
near-death experience expert John do
Colo was on Matt and Shane secret
podcast Jim gaffan was on the way back
podcast Tosh talked with his stylist the
blocks podcast had on rain Wilson Ari
shafir visited stav's World Pete Lee and
Rich boss went on you know what dude
Brennan saglo was on
first date talk to Johnny pton and
there's a new episode of the regs so
before I did comedy I was selling Comedy
Club tickets so I always had an excuse
to just approach a
[__] as far new standup comedy
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon Kevin James has a new
special titled irregardless that's out
right now on Prime video Jack whiteall
settled down is up on Netflix and
there's a few new projects out on
YouTube as well including Nate Jackson's
crowdwork joint and Tony cillis just
released a mini special on YouTube
titled Millennial man also a few
specials in the works right now that
will be coming out soon Jeff Dunham I'm
with cupid is coming out February 3rd on
Comedy Central followed by Taylor
Tomlinson have it all which is hitting
Netflix on February 13th and Mike EPS
has a new special coming out a week
after that titled ready to sell out it's
going to be very interesting to see how
this all plays out with the Legion of
skanks and their platform battle Rumble
and a have been thrown out so many times
now you'd have to think that one of
these major podcast is going to make the
jump soon but as far as joke World goes
you can feel free to follow us on X
Instagram Facebook Tik Tok or all of the
above right after checking out one of
the videos on the end screen thank you
for watching and be sure to keep an eye
out for the best of January coming
soon joke
World let it J
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out